you must have noticed recently some of
the food and products you buy are
shrinking it costing you more oh yeah
sally jaramillo went to a local grocery
store today and has more on the
shrink-flation trend and how you at home
can get the most product for your buck
[Music]
we're getting less but we're still
paying more angel valentine is a mother
of three she says inflation is making it
challenging for her family to get by i
would seem that where
the i would say the quality of products
have kind of gone down and what you're
actually getting the quality the
quantity as well for some that means
going back and forth to the store
because they are running out of things
quicker joel estrada district manager
for marketton grocery store agrees yeah
i've noticed that a lot of the packages
are being reduced on ounces or prices
and here at marketing there's an item
you probably haven't even paid attention
to start at the beginning of the year so
march you know february
they started reducing some of the
answers like on garyday you know from
32 onsites to 28 ounces
so
it's a new package
people don't notice and gatorade isn't
the only thing toilet paper too
detergents had gone down from 96 to 72
ounces brian wachter with the retail
association of nevada in a statement
says quote as a common alternative to
price increases more manufacturers are
making adjustments to the portion size
of some products consumers might
consider store brands price matching
policies and online markets as they shop
for their family's needs unquote and
while some say items they're kind of
going without estrada's best advice they
should be looking at nonsense
price per ounces
or unit price saliharamiyo live local
now